Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my breakdown of a new Batman
teaser that they just dropped Matt
Reeves revealed a first official look at
the new Batmobile and a full look like a
real full look at the new Batman suit so
we'll break it all down there's a bunch
of Easter eggs if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a bunch more coming
really soon so we'll just break this
down top-5 style on Easter eggs as we go
along starting with number 5 the final
look at the real version of the Batman
suit a couple weeks ago we got that
Batman teaser trailer that Matt Reeves
released
calling it a camera test of his costume
with a bunch of red kind of obscuring
what the actual color of the suit was
that was really just the cowl in the top
of the suit they just released it
because they were getting ready to film
in the cemetery which we then saw in
another teaser of them filming on set
with the Batman motorcycle but that was
the stunt man wearing a version of the
costume that had not been tuned up with
special-effects color correction or any
kind of post-production this image in
the new Batmobile teaser is what it's
actually going to look like in the movie
much much better seeing all the behind
the scenes stuff is a good teaser for
what stuff will look like it's a lot of
fun but nothing you see behind the
scenes is a hundred percent exactly what
its going to look like in the final version
of the movie really good example is
Henry Cavill Superman costume and Man of
Steel this is what it looked like in the
behind the scenes so same situation with
the new Batman suit it just to be clear
all these images in the previews of the
Batmobile and Batman underneath this
bridge this is what the actual movie is
going to look like they're using the
cameras and the sort of the look of the
movie as it's going to appear during the
film just confirming the neo-noir
detective thriller vibe that they've
been talking about the tone of the film
so number four the Batmobile in all its
retro glory I'm not a huge car guy
myself but clearly this is meant to be a
version of the Batmobile that Batman
creates from a real car so that you
could go walk out on the street and buy
much closer to an actual car than the
last two Batmobile is that Ben Affleck's
Batman and Christian Bale's Batman drove.
What's that?
Oh, the tumblr?
Oh you wouldn't be interested in
that.
The tumblr was more of a full-blown
military large-scale tank like vehicle
when they got to Ben Affleck's Batman
his Batmobile was a little more car-like
but still very much an urban assault
vehicle a smaller tank that could just
take corners a lot better for anyone who
lives in Los Angeles this is an actual
car that you might see driving down the
405 in the middle of the night just hot
rodding around number three what kind of
car is this based on and what has batt
me had done to upgrade it enter Batman
the Kit basher so if you're not
familiar with the concept of kit bashing
that's actually a term used in action
figure design where people will create
new action figures based on molds and
pieces from other action figures that
they've repurposed so in this context of
the Batmobile is Batman taking a couple
different parts from classic muscle cars
and putting them together to create a
new Batmobile I'm getting a very 1970s
American muscle car vibe seems pretty
evident like it's a little bit like a
1970s Mustang mixed with a Pontiac GTO
and then hot rotted out with all of
Batman's aftermarket upgrades and
modifications there's no shot of the
interior yet but based on the very retro
design language of the exterior I think
we can assume that a lot of the interior
functions and controls are very tactile
button like in keeping with the more
Keaton Batman 1966 Adam West's Batman
Batmobile
the newer Batmobiles like the tumbler
and the Affleck Batmobile also do have a
lot of buttons but by the time you get
to the more modern versions of the
Batmobile you start to see more and more
screen based tech it'll less retro tech
I don't know what kind of engine he's
dropped into this clearly it is massive
it is the biggest engine that I've ever
seen someone throw on a car but it's the
Batmobile so of course it's going to throw
a giant engine on it the fact that it's
exposed just gives it more of that
classic hot rod vibe I'm assuming that
also because he's added so much raw
horsepower to this that he's also
reinforced the frame and added a bunch
of armor plating to because obviously
he's going to be chasing down villains all
over the place and if Batman movie
tradition holds he will wind up
destroying most of this car through the
course of the film in his pursuit of
trying to catch the villains wouldn't be
a Batman movie if Batman didn't destroy
his toys just as much as he create
new ones speaking of the level of
technology even though they're going for
a very retro vibe we still don't have an
exact date for what year this movie is
supposed to take place I've heard 1990s
era but all the footage in the behind
the scenes we've seen so far makes it
kind of seem like there are some more
modern technology elements so they might
be going for a Batman the Animated
Series vibe when it comes to the way
they portray technology in the era that
this takes place during if you've never
watched any of the behind the scenes
features from Batman the Animated Series
Bruce Timm talks about their design
ethos for that series being driven by a
desire to make it seem timeless so a lot
of the cars the buildings Batman's
technology was very advanced but
designed to look like it was very
old-timey so in that same way a lot of
this Matt Reeves Batman movie tech seems
like it's retro like the Batmobile the
Batman suit Batman's motorcycle but
someone said that they saw iPhones on
some extras during a scene a couple
weeks ago so it sounds like they might
have iPhone level technology but a lot
of the buildings Batman's cars his
gadgets his suit is designed to look
kind of old timey number 2 the Easter
eggs so the biggest Batman comic book
and movie inspiration that I'm getting
from these pictures are the 1970s
Batmobile which was the Neal Adams era
Batman 1970s Batman basically which is
clearly inspired by a classic Corvette
American muscle car it is the sheer
real-world car look reminds me of the
original Batmobile when they first
appeared in the Batman comics in Adam
West's 1966 Batmobile which was a car
that they just modified for that TV show
if you're not familiar with the history
of the Batmobile there was no real
Batmobile when Batman first debuted in
the comics in 1939 his first actual car
that he drove with just a regular reg
convertible the Batmobile as you think
of it today didn't debut technically
till Batman number 5 a couple years
later in 1941 in that a little while
after that in Batman number 20 was the
first time that they featured the
Batmobile on the cover then as you can
see as they go through the years in the
next couple of Batmobiles they start to
look more in more comic book II more bat
inspired design language every once in a
while though a new designer will come
along like some of the more modern
Batmobiles seem a little more tank like
a little more classic like some of the
more modern ones even seem like they're
inspired by the design from Batman the
Animated Series I'm a big fan of the
Batmobile from Batman the Animated
Series one of the best ones the Batman
suit itself seems like it's mostly
inspired by the Arkham game suits in
berm a hose Batman suit a little more
toned down than the full-blown armor
suits that Ben Affleck's Batman wore not
including the Dark Knight Returns
leathery Batman suit from Batman vs
Superman or the full blown armor suit
also inspired by the other suit from
Frank Miller's Dark Knight Returns and a
little more retro than the Christian
Bale Batman suits number one what about
the gadgets so the retro design language
and the classic Batman nods make it seem
like he will also sport a lot of cool
gadgets just look at the projectiles on
this version of the suit those metal
pieces around his wrists seem a lot like
the court of the owls Talon suits
they're not just there to look cool
they're probably projectiles of some
kind look at his utility belt on the
stuntman here it's kind of hard to see
what's going on with that because it's a
little blurry but then there's also the
Batman symbol on his chest I know a lot
of you have the theory that he can pull
out the pieces and use them as batarangs
it's totally possible it does seem
pretty functional I still think it's
modified pieces of the gun that was used
by Joe Chill to kill his parents that'd
just be hardcore a lot of people also
think that that's kind of inspired by
Kevin Smith's story from Batman number
1000 where he literally melts down Joe
chills gun Andry forges it into a bat
symbol that he wears on his chest the
difference there is that the design of
that Batman symbol was much more classic
than the Robert Pattinson Batman symbol
which is way more angular way more
hardcore looking this just looks like
the parts are
taken from the two halves of the guns
handle but also yes look at the bottom
left and right edges that formed the
base of the wings it does look like
those parts have been sharpened in the
way that the symbol sits inside the
chest plate makes it seem like he could
yank it out and throw the pieces of
someone or use them as weapons if he
needed to I think part of the idea with
robert pattinson x' Batman designs his
car everything about his suit is that
it's all made to be functional
everything serves a purpose there was
also a recent Riddler scene from the
Batman movie that leaked a week or two
ago from one of his victims in the movie
I can't put the scene in the video here
because I don't want to get super banned
but it was very reminiscent of the viral
marketing that they did for The Dark
Knight
this new scene of the Batman movie that
leaked out was one of the Riddler's
victims sitting in a chair all tied up
wrapped in bloody bandages with a sign
hanging on him with a big question mark
in blood that read no more lies the
Bamian trailer should arrive later this
year in December but there might be some
smaller teasers before then so I'll do
as many videos as I can for everything
leave all your video requests in the
comments below and let me know if you
spotted any other easter eggs in these
previews that I didn't mention in the
video there's a couple of their big
Marvel and DC videos that I'm working on
I'll try to post those as soon as I can
everyone click here for all my new
Batman teaser trailer and Easter egg
videos and click here for my brand-new
Marvel Wolverine video.
Thank you so much for watching. Everyone stay awesome.
I'll see you guys tonight!